i speak to you today
with feelings of profound sorrow
throughout her life her majesty the
queen
my beloved mother
was an inspiration an example to me
and to all my family
and we owe her the most heartfelt debt
any family could owe to their mother
for her love
affection
guidance
and example
queen elizabeth was a life well lived
a promise with destiny kept
and she is mourned most deeply in her
passing that promise of lifelong service
i renew to you all today
alongside the personal grief that all my
family are feeling
we also share with so many of you in the
united kingdom
in all the countries where the queen was
head of state
in the commonwealth
and across the world
a deep sense of gratitude
for the more than 70 years in which my
mother as queen
served the people of so many nations
in 1947
on her 21st birthday
she pledged in a broadcast from cape
town
to the commonwealth
to devote her life
whether it be short or long
to the service of her peoples
that was more than a promise
it was a profound
personal commitment
which defined her whole life
she made sacrifices for duty
her dedication
and devotion of sovereign
never wavered
through times of change and progress
through times of joy
and celebration
and through times of sadness and loss
in her life of service
we saw that abiding love of tradition
together with that fearless embrace of
progress
which makes us great as nations
the affection
admiration and respect she inspired
became the hallmark of her reign
and as every member of my family can
testify
she combined these qualities with warmth
humor
and
an unerring ability always to see the
best in people
i pay tribute to my mother's memory
and i honor her life of service
i know that her death brings great
sadness to so many of you
and i share that sense of loss beyond
measure with you all
when the queen came to the throne
britain
and the world were still coping with the
privations
and aftermath of the second world war
and still living by the conventions of
earlier times
in the course of the last 70 years
we have seen our society become
one of many cultures and many faiths
the institutions of the state
have changed in turn
but through all changes and challenges
our nation
and the wider family of realms
of whose talents traditions
and achievements
i am so inexpressibly proud have
prospered and flourished
our values have remained
and must remain
constant
the role
and the duties of monarchy also remain
as does the sovereign's
particular relationship and
responsibility
towards the church of england
the church
in which my own faith is so deeply
rooted
in that faith and the values it inspires
i have been brought up to cherish a
sense of duty to others
and to hold in the greatest respect
the precious traditions freedoms and
responsibilities
of our unique history
and our system of parliamentary
government
as the queen herself did with such
unswerving devotion
i too now
solemnly pledge myself
throughout the remaining time god grants
me
to uphold the constitutional principles
at the heart of our nation
and wherever you may live in the united
kingdom or in the realms and territories
across the world
and whatever may be your background or
beliefs
i shall endeavor to serve you with
loyalty
respect
and love
as i have throughout my life
my life will of course change
as i take up my new responsibilities
it will no longer be possible for me to
give so much of my time and energies to
the charities and issues
for which i care so deeply
but i know this important work will go
on
in the trusted hands of others
this is also a time of change for my
family
i count
on the loving help of my darling wife
camilla
in recognition of her own loyal public
service since our marriage 17 years ago
she becomes my queen consult
i know
she will bring to the demands of her new
role
the steadfast devotion to duty on which
i have come to rely so much
as my heir
william
now assumes the scottish titles which
have meant so much to me
he succeeds me as duke of cornwall
and takes on the responsibilities for
the duchy of cornwall which i have
undertaken for more than five decades
today
i am proud to create him prince of wales
to whistle comrade
the country
whose title i've been so greatly
privileged to bear
during so much of my life and duty
with catherine beside him
our new prince and princess of wales
will i know
continue to inspire and lead our
national conversations
helping to bring the marginal to the
center ground
where vital help can be given
i want also to express
my love for harry and megan
as they continue to build their lives
overseas
in a little over a week's time
we will come together as a nation
as a commonwealth and indeed a global
community
to lay my beloved mother to rest
in our sorrow
let us remember
and draw strength from the light of her
example
on behalf of all my family
i can only offer
the most sincere
and heartfelt thanks
for your condolences and support
they mean more to me than i can ever
possibly express
and to my darling mama
as you begin your last great journey
to join my dear late papa
i want simply to say this
thank you
thank you
for your love
and devotion
to our family
and to the family of nations you have
served so diligently all these years
may
flights of angels
sing thee to thy rest